[Music]
today's question comes from alicia in
arkansas
man this is a good one two months ago we
started on the baby steps
my husband made a budget and i'm
sticking to it there isn't much wiggle
room to lower the budget is we have
three children
my husband works two jobs from 6 30 a.m
to 12 30 a.m
i have a day job where i can bring our
two youngest children so we don't have
child care costs
my husband thinks that if i was truly on
board with getting out of debt
i'd get a second job caring for our
children and home is
already a full-time job and i can't be
away from home as many hours as he is
could i please have some guidance as to
what is realistic for me to do
can i tell you when i first read this
you know what it sounds like
it sounds like an exhausted dad and an
exhausted husband
and who's i feel stuck feels stuck and
so he's getting this comparative
sacrifice game i'm sacrificing more than
you so my sacrifice is more valuable
than yours and
man that's just a that's an exhausted
person who's out of steam and out of gas
and needs to take a break for a second
before everything just burns down
that's hard yeah there's one of two
things going on in the math there
yeah both of which are causing stuck or
either of which is called
causing stuck uh thing one is the income
is very low
yep even though he's working like crazy
he's not making any money okay
and so there's not enough income to just
keep the wolf away from the door so to
speak
um if that's the case you have a career
ken coleman moment here you need to be
thinking about working smarter not
harder and i know that's cliche but you
probably need to not make minimum
freaking wage and work 800 hours
you cannot get ahead doing that so
you've got to do something where you
make
more money if that's the case the other
possible thing is you're making plenty
of money
but you're sitting on two forty five
thousand dollar cars with eight hundred
dollar payments
and you're suggesting that she go do
this instead of selling these stupid but
cars you have or this house you bought
that you can't afford the house payment
is fifty percent of your take-home pay
and you sell the stinking house uh
something is in the log
jam here and you know the old
lumberjacks in the old days my
great-great-grandfather
david l the first was a owned a lumber
company back in the turn of the century
and they would cut timber in kentucky or
uh eastern tennessee or western north
carolina and they would
uh the huge logs they put them in the
river and that's how they transported
them
there were no big trucks and they float
them and they'd ride them
and poke them and if the river had a
horseshoe bin it hit in the corner
those logs would would pile up and
that's called a
log jam jam yeah that's the name yeah
you know how they fix the log jam
throw dynamite in the middle of it blow
it up
and then the thing is you know blow some
of them out and they start flowing
around again
so you throw dynamite in the middle of a
log jams how you fix it and so when
you've got a mathematical log jam you
got to blow it up yeah yeah sell the
house you gotta sell the cars you gotta
sell everything in sight yep
and so either you've got a bunch of
things around there that the payments on
you can't afford
or you have an income issue it might be
a little of both but it's probably
distinctly one or the other
what are the chances of a number three
that i've heard
throughout my career which is a guy goes
to work
this is a traditionally a guy goes to
work and works real hard and thinks his
wife is just quote unquote sitting
around at home
she just gets to play with the kids all
day well i'm off x y and z and
it'd be nice if she got off her butt
every once in a while and went and did
it you know
yeah i run into that sometimes uh
but most of the time it's because he
doesn't think
that we can make it if she doesn't oh so
it's
it's
it still goes back to a math problem i
mean most of the time
there's that sense of we're stuck in
other words let's say this
let's say okay he's working and she he
thinks she's kind of sitting on her butt
but he's making 300 000 a year and they
got no money problems yeah
that usually doesn't come up then right
he goes okay sit there and eat bon bons
you know i mean
you know and he's kind of doesn't that
maybe there's some respect issues or
something like that
but he's not like slamming his fist on
the kitchen table going once you go to
work you lazy
okay bomb right right you know he
doesn't that usually doesn't come up
there
where it comes up is when things are
tight yeah usually scary
usually i'm scared i feel stuck i feel
hopeless
uh you know hope deferred makes the
heart
sick proverb says and so that that's
kind of what's going on so i
you know i'm with you i don't think this
is a bad guy i think he's a tired guy
or a stuck guy and he can't see his way
out and he's
going we got to do something and his
version of dynamite
is putting the wife out again yeah you
know go you know you're not making
enough i'm doing all i can do so you
gotta row harder and i always want
somebody this reminds me my grandmother
used to tell me
she after she had her fourth kid she
always wanted to go back to work
and my granddad used to say we can't
afford you to go back to work because
child care costs were so expensive
and they've accelerated exponentially
since back then
and so i always want to model this out
too before you go get a second job
here's what's going to cost to put two
or three kids in daycare and
buy professional clothing and put the
car
on the road more and uh fatigue
food because i'm not here to cook there
you go um and
uh pre-prepared foods more expensive
than cooking from scratch
also not as good for you but it takes
more time
at home to cook prepared for i mean from
scratch so
yeah there's tons of value that the home
economist
economically actually brings that's
exactly right so there's something about
you two need to get away for a minute
and just stop and say where are we
yeah where are we yeah he he's a
hard-working guy he's
not a bad guy and she's hard worker too
yeah he they both are but i mean she's
pretty pissed at him the way i agree
between the lines here oh yeah she
didn't like that
no she didn't like him calling her lazy
no yeah
and when i see somebody working full
time and taking two kids to work with
them they're not right yeah they're not
she's not
yeah they're in a log jam i like that i
like that analogy dave sometimes you
just got to throw dynamite in it and say
we need to figure something out
somebody's got to blow up here because
what we're doing is not working keep
doing the same thing over and over again
definition of insanity expecting a
different result